Kanzler Olaf Scholz sucht in diesen
Tagen nach Energie nach Energie für uns
hier in Deutschland Energie die er nun
dringend notwendig ist um die deutsche
Industrie am Laufen zu halten seit einem
halben Jahr kämpft die ampelregierung
jetzt schon für Flüssiggas aus den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten bislang
vergeblich die katarreise von
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck im
März leider ein Reinfall jetzt ist
Scholz in der Golfregion pflanzt dort
aber erst einmal einen Baum mitten in
der Wüste weil wie sagte Luther schon
wenn ich wüsste dass morgen die Welt
unterginge würde ich heute noch ein
Apfelbäumchen pflanzen
ja Scholz sucht also Energiepartner am
Golf und er lots tatsächlich ein Schiff
nach Deutschland immerhin Ende des
Jahres pünktlich zu Weihnachten soll es
ankommen an Bord rund 140.000 Kubikmeter
Gas ein erster klitzekleiner Erfolg ein
einzelnes Schiff denn alle wissen
zuletzt flossen aus der Gaspipeline Nord
Stream 1 alleine an einem Tag mehr
Kilowattstunden als jetzt der gesamte
lng-t mit den Emiraten umfasst und es
geht auch in eine neue Runde im Duell um
die gasumlage seit Wochen streiten jetzt
schon die ampelparteien um den Plan von
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck ab
Oktober sollen alle Gasverbraucher 2,4
Cent pro Kilowattstunde extra zahlen um
angeschlagene gasimporteure vor der
Insolvenz zu retten jetzt Spitze ich der
ampelzoff um 50 Milliarden Euro weiter
zu Bundesfinanzminister Christian Linder
geht in die Offensive was er statt
harvex murksgesetz jetzt plant jetzt
die gasumlage würde ja die Gaspreise
weiter verteuern da stellt sich jetzt
die wirtschaftliche Sinnfrage in dieser
Situation ich glaube wir brauchen die
bei der strompreisbremse so etwas auch
am Gasmarkt eine gaspreisbremse muss
schnell und wirksam die Verbraucherinnen
und Verbraucher und die Wirtschaft
gleichermaßen entlasten daran arbeiten
wir innerhalb der Bundesregierung hier
auch bereits mit einer Kommission und
ich werde im Finanzministerium darauf
achten und daran arbeiten dass die
Gaspreis Bremse nicht die langfristige
Tragfähigkeit unserer Staatsfinanzen
gefährdet die Schuldenbremse für den
Bundeshaushalt steht also und über die
gasumlage sprechen wir jetzt bei uns im
Studium mit bildpolitikchef Jan Schäfer
schönen guten Morgen Jan guten Morgen
ist die gasumlage also jetzt Geschichte
es sieht ganz so aus die gasumlage soll
am Mittwoch eigentlich vom
Bundeskabinett beschlossen werden also
in gut 48 Stunden von jetzt angerechnet
aber wir können glaube ich den Countdown
jetzt zurückziehen und sagen nein das
wird nichts mehr werden es gibt einfach
ganz viele Vorbehalte und kein einziger
Bundesminister steht noch richtig hinter
dieser gasumlage von daher würde ich
sagen sie ist tot was treibt unser
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Hawk da
eigentlich für ein Spiel also ich meine
letzte Woche verteidigt er noch die
gasumlage im Bundestag und jetzt schiebt
er dieses Paket Christian Lindner unter
und sagt bitte einmal
finanzverfassungsrechtlich prüfen lassen
ja es ist ein unwürdiges schwarze
peterspiel was wieder sehen von Habeck
zu Lindner und dann auch von Lindner zu
Innenministerin Nancy fazer denn wie
sagte der Finanzminister gestern Abend
sie ist am Ende auch diejenige die das
dann verfassungsrechtlich prüfen muss
also da gibt es drei Minister die da
jetzt diese gasumlage unter sich
ausmachen bzw deren Begräbnis eigentlich
organisieren dass wir insgesamt sehen
glaube ich das kann man am heutigen
Montagmorgen sagen diese Bundesregierung
steht kurz vor der Kernschmelze man hat
wirklich den Eindruck und zwar wenn man
in alle Ressorts reinschaut
die Ministerinnen und Minister sind
dieser Krise offenbar dieser
gigantischen Krise muss man auch sagen
offenbar nicht richtig gewachsen es
fehlt einfach extrem auch an
ökonomischen Sachverstand was würdest Du
raten du hast ökonomischen Sachverstand
angesprochen sollte sie Bundesregierung
sich vielleicht jetzt von außerhalb
Beratung reinholen was wäre dein
Vorschlag es gibt einige Bundesminister
die das ja machen aber wenn wir sehen
wie beispielsweise Robert Habeck sein
Wirtschaftsministerium aufgestellt hat
seinen engsten Kreis um sich herum dann
muss man sagen dann geht es dort vor
allem um Ideologie aber nicht um
Ökonomie und das ist für ein
Wirtschaftsminister sicherlich das
Falscheste was er tun kann es gibt in
diesem Land viele viele auch sehr
renommierte Ökonomen die sich immer
wieder zu Wort melden beispielsweise
Clemens Fuß den ifo-präsidenten oder
auch Lars Feld der ist Berater von
Christian Lindner und die haben von
Anfang an sowohl die gasumlage für
falsch gehalten beispielsweise aber auch
sagen diese gaspreisdeckelung die jetzt
kommen soll weiß nicht das richtige
sondern viele namhafte Ökonomen sagen
was das Beste wäre wäre gezielt
diejenigen zu unterstützen
möglicherweise nicht nur mit 300 oder
mit 1000 Euro sondern mit noch mehr die
ist ganz ganz dringend nötig haben also
das sind gerade Geringverdiener da sind
die sozialschwächeren oder auch kleine
mittelständische Betriebe es knirscht
nach wie vor jetzt ja auch die
Hiobsbotschaft Strom weg in Deutschland
das kann in diesem Winter tatsächlich
passieren die Folge der Energiekrise ist
droht der große Blackout so und jetzt
ist sich natürlich jeder unsicher was
passiert denn dann genau schlussendlich
um den ganz großen Blackout zu
verhindern kann sich unsere Regierende
Bürgermeisterin Franziska Giffey
vorstellen in einzelnen Stadtteilen
nacheinander für wenige Stunden die
Stromversorgung präventiv abzuschalten
was hältst du von diesem Vorschlag
ja also das lässt einen fassungslos
zurück vor allem haben wir alle noch im
Ohr glaube ich und es war wieder einmal
der Bundeswirtschaftsminister und viele
seiner grünen Parteifreunde die doch
eigentlich uns die ganze Zeit erzählt
haben wir hätten gar kein Stromproblem
das ist ja wirklich ganz bemerkenswert
interessant offenbar haben wir doch eins
und umso bemerkenswerter ist weiterhin
das Robert Habeck beispielsweise die
drei Kernkraftwerke auch unbedingt
abschalten möchte zum Jahreswechsel was
der Stromproblem eher größer denn
kleiner machen würde was wir hier sehen
das erinnert mich an Ländern in denen
die wirtschaftliche Stabilität lange
nicht so ist wie in Deutschland wir
reden über die viertgrößte
Industrienation der Welt und in der
Hauptstadt sollen also jetzt
stundenweise dann Haushalte und auch
Firmen vom Stromnetz genommen werden
dass muss in jedem Fall verhindert
werden es riecht nach einem Aprilscherz
ist leider keiner und wir haben die
Berliner Bürger gefragt was sie dazu
sagen den Strom präventiv abzuschalten
und schauen uns jetzt mal an
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen einfach
irgendeinen stadtteilz nehmen und für
ein paar Stunden den Strom abzustellen
ich meine gibt das fairerweise zu machen
glaube ich eher nicht also ich finde das
ein bisschen extreme Maßnahmen da gibt
es Kraftwerke diese wiederum betriebenen
kennen und alles mögliche warum wollen
die die abschalten die Kraftwerke ich
kenne das ich komme aus Polen wir haben
das schon mal durchgelebt das sind die
schöne Zeiten und ich würde mir wünschen
dass wir alles andere machen nur und ich
das ich habe auch gesehen sie wollen um
10 Uhr alles schon ausmachen 15 Uhr bis
4 Uhr denken das ist auch crazy wie kann
man leben so dass es da ja schafft man
das nichts was würden Sie dann machen
gar nicht ins Bett gehen mit meinem Mann
der Strom Blackout steht im Raum auch
wenn die BürgerInnen sagen das hoffen
wir nicht dass das eintritt was werden
denn jetzt die kurzfristigen Maßnahmen
die den Strom Blackout verhindern würden
ja es geht am Ende darum dass wir ein
wachsenden Stromhunger haben und vor
allem im Winter natürlich der
Strombedarf gigantisch groß ist einfach
weil wir mehr Energie und auch mehr
Strom brauchen wird früher dunkel es
wird später hell von daher müssen wir
alle früher die Lichter anmachen und
später ausmachen was kann kurzfristig
helfen kurzfristig kann mit Sicherheit
helfen dass wir die drei Kernkraftwerke
die zum Jahresende vom Netz gehen sollen
definitiv nicht vom Netz nähen nehmen
kurzfristig kann sicherlich auch helfen
auch wenn es für sozusagen die Luft und
den CO2-Ausstoß sehr sehr nachteilig ist
Kohlekraftwerke zusätzlich ans Netz zu
nehmen dort sehen wir dass die
Laufzeiten viel zu kurz bemessen sind
derjenigen Kraftwerke die wieder ans
Netz sollen also auch da muss man sich
überlegen dass man die Laufzeit
verlängert dass es sich lohnt
Kohlekraftwerke ans Netz zu nehmen das
sind alles Dinge die dazu beitragen
können dass wir einigermaßen stromsicher
durch den Winter kommen aber um das
einmal noch klar zu sagen es geht bei
den Grünen so etwas wie eine romantische
Vorstellung Robert Habeck hat selbst ein
Kinderbuch geschrieben da geht es auch
um Stromausfälle da geht es darum wie
schön eigentlich so ein Stromausfall
sein kann er verwechselt glaube ich das
Kinderbuch mit der viertgrößten
Volkswirtschaft dieser Welt
das war schönes für Kinder was
vielleicht auch ganz kuschelig klingt
das darf in diesem Land nicht passieren
der hängt einfach viel zu viel dran da
hängt Krankenhäuser dran da hängen ganz
ganz viele Arbeitsplätze dran der hängt
unser Wohlstand dran und deswegen das
was Kinderbuch Romantik ist hat nichts
im realen Leben hier bei uns zu suchen
sagt Bild politikchef Jan Schäfer
herzlichen Dank für deine Einschätzung
[Musik]